[Musik]
in fellbach in baden-württemberg haben
sich die stadtwerke ganz böse verrechnet
dem privaten betreiber des örtlichen
freizeitbades werden über einen zeitraum
von sechs jahren sagenhafte 640.000
kubikmeter wasser zu wenig in rechnung
gestellt der schaden für die stadt 2,3
millionen euro zahlen mussten dass alle
fellbacher gebührenzahler die können es
nicht glauben weil peinlicher geht es ja
gar nicht und da ist der ganze
wasserpreis auf alle anwohner umgelegt
worden also es ist wirklich das ist es
auffällt ist traurig dass das keiner
markt hat und ist auch nie in die
richtung kontrolliert wurde ich
persönlich eine frechheit dass schon
wieder ein fehler der sollte eigentlich
nicht passieren
2013 wird das neue bad eröffnet
betrieben von einer privaten firma um
den verbrauch zu messen bauen die
stadtwerke ein wasserzähler ein absolut
routine sollte man meinen aber weit
gefehlt
durch eine aneinanderreihung von fehlern
beim einbau des zählers und beim anlegen
in unserem abrechnungssystem war so dass
wir über jahre hinweg mit dem falschen
faktor abgerechnet haben dadurch ist
unseren kunden den schaden beim frisch
war so in höhe von 1,2 millionen euro
entstanden
und beim schmutzwasser in höhe von 1,1
millionen euro wegen corona droht das
bad 2020 pleite zu gehen
die stadt übernimmt deshalb das bad
komplett mit allen lasten und risiken
erst jetzt entdecken die stadtwerke
ihrem kapitalen abrechnungsfehler der
vormalige betreiber der viel zu wenig
bezahlt hat kann nicht mehr belangt
werden wenn bei mir das wasser zwei
monate läuft ja wenn ich zwei monate
nichts zahlen
dann kommen sie unseren sind ganze ab
das ist ganz klar also dass usa hoffen
dass das nicht stimmen können die zu
viel gezahlten wassergebühren wollen die
stadtwerke den fellbacher haushalten
erstatten
der chef der stadtwerke versucht erst
garnicht das abrechnungs desaster
kleinzureden wir haben wir fehler
gemacht
sehr ärgerliche fehler ich war auch
persönlichen wirklich erschüttert als
ich das festgestellt habe und ich kann
mich dafür nur entschuldigen
immerhin wie einsicht ist da denn auch
die bürger halten die planer für einfach
nur peinlich bezahlt keine
kontrollinstanz und guckt halt keiner
genau drauf ich denke dass ich täglich
damit beschäftigt wer hätte das schon
früher merken sollte doch hätte das bei
2,3 millionen schon früher auffallen
müssen auf jeden fall also ich finde
eigentlich richtige frechheit dass der
steuerzahler das jetzt auch noch
übernehmen soll
denn die millionen zeche muss jetzt aus
der stadtkasse bezahlt werden und dieses
geld wird dann irgendwo an anderer
stelle in fellbach fehlen